Joe Biden has a nickname for Donald
Trump you thought Trump had good
nicknames or wait'll you hear Joe's
nickname for the president they fail to
get this money out to the folks who
desperately needed to stay afloat is it
incompetence corruption Trump is out
there tweeting again this morning I
called President Tweety reopened the
country end of quote how are we supposed
to do that if you're sitting on the
money small businesses need in order to
stay alive stop tweeting about it get
the money out to Main Street now is
there it's been passed this pandemic is
hitting everyone hard we need serious
competent leadership now more than ever
President Tweety I call him president
Tweety yeah it took me it took we got
three years to think of that one but I
think it's pretty good I think it's I'm
gonna send it in to Bob Hope see if he
uses the joke president Tweety
that's very lame that's not a good
nickname you know Donald Trump came up
with some of the best nicknames in
recent political memory right he had low
energy Jeb little Marco or you had the
crook crooked hillary was a stroke of
genius crooked Hillary totally nailed
her sleepy Joe another stroke of genius
at the time a lot of people said mr.
president why aren't you gonna call him
creepy Joe cuz they were all talking
about how Joe would smell people's hair
and stuff now that wasn't as good the
attack on Joe Biden is not that Joe
Biden is some secret villainous
mastermind pedophile no that's not it
it's that he is a senile and doddering
man who even in his prime wasn't
particularly smart wasn't particularly
with it
[Music]
you
[Music]